what's better than eating food and
watching Netflix eating food while
watching food on Netflix
it's the double-double of nights on the
couch the extra garlic bread with your
pizza delivery consumption upon
consumption I might only been living in
America for a year but I've been here
long enough to know that you guys are
into that more is more am i right
so putting that seamless order fire up
your Chrome browser finally install that
annoying Silverlight update and take
your pick from our roundup of the best
food documentaries to stream on Netflix
right now I don't believe in saving the
best to last so let's start with a
michelin-starred mecca of Netflix food
docs diet without that you might be once
you call yep there you go so you need
this order if you haven't watched jiro
Dreams of Sushi then what you've really
been doing with your life and if you
have watched juror Dreams of Sushi
you're probably asking yourself the same
thing you almost certainly haven't been
doing what Jiro has been doing which is
dedicating yourself to the pursuit of
culinary perfection Jiro Ono is 400
years old and he still spends his days
artfully composing the best sushi in the
world at is tensity restaurant in a
Tokyo subway station if you do today
quantity not the computer would be naked
no really what are you doing with your
life prepared to feel inspired
enlightened hungry and pathetic very
pathetic are pretty much the opposite
end of the spectrum we have our next pic
super-sized me the original gross-out
food documentary is still one of the
most entertaining out there it's fast
food really that bad for you I mean what
would happen if I ate nothing but
McDonald's for 30 days straight you'll
die I want more more more and more to
stock in case you're unfamiliar with the
premise it goes something like this
filmmaker Morgan Spurlock eats only
McDonald's for a month tracks the impact
on his physical and mental health and
concludes that McDonald's is pretty much
the devil
if you're still grappling with the
Mickey D's habit watching Spurlock
regurgitate his double cheeseburger meal
on day two of the experiment losers
should pretty much put you off for life
you're welcome
it's hot in the kitchen it's physical
mentally taxing you got one chance every
night to get it right for the customers
which are paying and expecting
perfection
if you thought Gordon Ramsay was a moody
British get just wait till you meet chef
pool Leibrandt technically a Zimbabwean
Leibrandt grew up in London before
moving to the u.s. to establish himself
as the enfant irregular of the new york
dining scene he quickly became the
youngest chef to earn a three-star
review from the New York Times and then
kind of messed it up by being a
difficult egomaniac everywhere he went
you send me two pieces up like that
again I'll put your both heads to the
[ __ ] wall
I'm not on that case I'm just an artist
it's basically a story about when
keeping it real goes wrong and then goes
right and then maybe goes wrong again
either way gripping stuff if you like
your food porn on the sweet side then
you're going to get off on this one
the judges are going to eat 16 cakes if
we don't get this I will never get over
it
16 French pastry chefs three days one
chance to be crowned the best dessert
craftsman in France the sugar sculptures
are high the stakes even more so and the
competition gets pretty intense meringue
is not a joke people be sure to have an
M&M supply within arm's reach for
convenience stress eating throughout the
film Thank You Lucas Arrington
all right so Pierson has CMAs delivered
your cheeseburger yet they have good and
I'll put it down because you definitely
don't want to be eating meat while you
watch this one the industry doesn't want
you to know the truth about what you're
eating because if you knew you might not
want to eat it everything we've done in
modern agriculture is to grow it faster
fatter bigger cheaper food Inc debunks
the pastoral myth you're sold along with
that 12 ounce sirloin and exposes the
reality of the u.s. agricultural
industry in all its stomach-churning
glory
this isn't forming this is just mass
production like an assembly line in a
factory if you think vegans are a bunch
of granola-crunching Muppets then
fooding might help you to see that point
you have been warned still hungry for
more check out first we feast for more
great food Felix you greedy greedy git